it's so funny coleman that i think most
people with like 2020 2021 like it's not
a banner year for people
but you're like firing on all cylinders
you got so much going on
between 20 20 21 like what does it feel
like to be having such a moment right
now
oh man it feels it feels it feels really
good to be honest i i won't even lie it
feels like
it does feel like i'm firing on all
cylinders i feel
super creative i feel like all the
projects that i have been
that i've been giving my heart to have
been working on have been
amplified so it feels great i'm not even
gonna lie it feels it feels great it
feels
because also it's like i usually you
know i've been working for 30 years and
i do my work and
and a lot of times you do it to a little
fanfare
and but right now it seems like there's
a lot of fanfare on the things that i've
been doing and i'm i'm telling you i'm
taking it
yeah you should no you should yeah
speaking of fanfare
first indie spirit nomination how does
that feel oh i feel i was so surprised
that was
where was i i was at work i was on set
all right and um
and yeah and and i was i came back to my
chair
and my phone was lit up with like 20
messages and i was like
what's going on and i saw my publicist
and managers and everything so i knew it
was something professional
but i didn't know because i don't think
of that because i actually just don't
think of those things
and so i i called my my uh publishers
like
i can't believe your phone was internal
i said i'm on set why what's going on
and then she told me and i just couldn't
stop laughing i think that's my reaction
to anything wonderful i just started
laughing a lot because it just feels
it's like i just feel giddy and i'm like
that is the sweetest the coolest thing
and what about like your family what did
your husband say you know what he was
just
he gets i think i love the fact that he
gets even more excited than i do
i love the work i love the work and the
craftsmanship of all of it i love going
to work
and um and then i think if you're
awarded or nominated for something
it's a nice bonus but he he really likes
it because i think that it's sort of um
i know that he holds a lot of esteem for
my work and it's important for me to be
respected
and so i think he it feels really good
to him because he's like oh people are
recognizing my work and who doesn't want
to be recognized so i
let them hold that and i believe
but i mean really like maharani's black
bottom is clearly going to be it already
is
one of the major movies like getting a
bunch of you know award nominations and
stuff like that like
how do you approach award season
obviously it's going to be a very
different award season this year but
mentally how do you approach like all
these athletes coming towards the movie
i i think with that with a grain of salt
i think i've been a part of such
incredible works that
possibly didn't get a lot of attention
so i think that
i'm a bit um i don't know a bit more
steadfast about these things i feel like
i'm like
i just take it as like it's wonderful to
be recognized i also it's nice to be in
great company but i don't um i don't i
don't think about the winning of it it
would be nice to think i never think
that far because maybe that jinx
jinx things to me for me so i think it's
just important to just
enjoy being fed and being a part of the
festivities
i i'm that guy who will then you know i
don't get nervous before an award show
or something like that i will have a
cocktail i will eat the snacks
i'm not sitting on a pen's needle
because i'm like i don't want to miss
the moment
i want to enjoy all of it yeah you know
so i'm just in the moment and i
so that's the way i prepare just being
in the moment being ready but
yeah that's awesome yeah so my rainy's
black bottom it's actually my favorite
movie of the year i've seen most of the
contenders at this point
yeah it's my favorite movie of the year
like i was such a huge fan
of chad book and i find it so
interesting some of the other actors
that have talked about working with chad
in these last few years like
clark peters talked about working on
different defied bloods and said
you know his perception shooting that
movie that chadwick came off a little
bit egotistical because he had all these
people around him
you know taking care of him kind of
thing of course now his perspective has
changed i know viola talked about
that he would fall asleep on set
sometimes
standing up in between takes so one what
was your perception of chadwick when
you're shooting the movie
from rehearsal to shooting chadwick had
a lot of i felt like he had a great
enthusiasm he was funny
um i looked at some behind the scenes
and you always see the two of us
hanging on each other laughing because
we love to work and we also love to
kid around with each other and he was
joyful to be around and he
he worked hard he worked hard when i
tell you
it was a running joke where like we
always knew that even if chad did
seven takes of a certain amount of
coverage uh george say
are you ready to move on he says one
more one chad always wanted one more
and that's why i truly respected him so
he was a blast to work with and we went
to some really
deep places i think that really there's
that one scene in particular
that i know i've spoken about where
where we have questions of faith
and our characters really come to blows
and it was painful to do
because it brings up things in your own
um your own spirit
um in your own questions about god's
uh will and so uh we uh i just remember
us
just embracing each other after that
scene because we're so painful to do but
we knew we needed each other to do that
work
i think what i truly when i when i
witness my rainy's black bottom
i see that extraordinary ensemble
in us giving each other and feeding each
other our performances
and so that's that's so clear yeah
that's so clear watch that movie too
yeah the chemistry you all have together
is absolutely amazing
but now like now that you know what you
know about what chad was going through
like does your whole perception of that
experience
change it's bittersweet because i wish
my brother was
sitting right here with me you know
doing press and talking about how
work is being received so it's been it's
all bittersweet it's it
it still feels like i'm a bit in a bit
of a dream because um every so often i
forget that he's gone
because he's so alive on that screen and
he's so alive
i mean he bought me a record player
that's right in my living room for
my rap gift and so i play vinyl on it
every night when i'm home
and so i feel like i feel his presence
because he is that alive to me
he had that much charisma and that much
of influence so he's always with me
that's what i feel to be honest yeah
now euphoria that episode coleman
that episode years a day was absolutely
amazing what was the experience of dude
it was just the two of you right
yes and it was the first thing i did
after lockdown and uh sam sam handed me
a script that i thought
i had been given the keys to the kingdom
it was so rich
and i i think it dealt with everything
that was on my mind and questioning
about
our society and who we are in our
humanity and i was able to
you know and and we would deliver this
it was amazing because
the set was quiet and it was basically
me and zendaya and a very limited
um uh crew and we just we just gave it
our all
and it feels like a meditation to be
honest i felt like
it felt like a christmas gift at the end
of 2020
um for you to sit down and have a hard
conversation
with two people who have nothing to lose
the they're two addicts
and who who else is going to be more
honest than two addicts on christmas eve
i i have the time of my life and i've
i've been
dude the i've been overwhelmed with the
the feelings about that episode they
come in on the daily
to my twitter feed and facebook you name
it and i love it because i feel like i'm
a part of a great conversation
about people trying to get well and
understanding the disease of addiction
that at our best that's what i feel like
i truly feel like when we're doing our
best work
and we have a great intention and we get
that response i feel like it's all
synergy so i feel amazing
yeah yeah i talked to zendaya i guess
about a week and a half ago
about uh malcolm and marie and we talked
about this
this uh perception out there that people
think she can't play adult roles and she
was saying
yeah she understands a little bit that
she played 16 for a long time so it's a
little bit of a transition happening
yeah what's your response for someone
that works alongside her what's your
response to people thinking like she
can't
play adult roles i just want people to
not limit her that this young woman can
do anything she's super human she can
sing she can dance she can act
she's playing a 17 year old but i think
what is she 23 or something
anyone who sat down with her will know
that uh
will understand her complexity and her
depth so i think you know
people just need to open up their minds
in their heart store and just let her be
human and be
as complex as she is you know right now
another thing you're doing that i
absolutely love is bottomless brunch at
coleman's
i love what you're doing there and
that's the whole thing about like
like i mean pivoting in the pandemic
like everyone's had to so yeah what's
the experience
for you been like like doing the show
and like oh she's still at the bar like
what's it been like
it's it's been awesome because i thought
the first thing i thought was i still
wanted to have
people over because i'm a very sociable
person and i always have people look for
dinners and brunches you name it
and i thought there was a way to do it
virtually and we can bring in
you know people that i want to get to
know each other like common and yaya
abdul mateen and
nishi nash and nicholas braun you name
it and so these are all my friends and i
thought oh great we'll send them a
cocktail
we'll we'll set up amc we're so into the
idea and we just have
great companies we have some fun we play
some silly games and then we go into
some really deep conversations it's just
like brunch
so uh we're now on our season three
which is cool because apparently it's
been popular so we're gonna keep going
i guess as long as i got friends
you know so apparently so i'm gonna
invite you next apparently yeah
i'm down i'll make a cocktail sure yeah
has anything surprised you about doing
it this way
you know what what surprised me is that
it's touching people in a way that i
i i thought people needed and it's
and it's doing the thing that i wanted
to do which was just bring
it's 20 minutes bring a little sunshine
in your life get to know people in a
different way
because the show is not about promoting
anything i don't want to an actor
comment and i didn't talk about
his next album our next film we talked
about common and what inspires him and
i want i want to pull the curtain back
and for you to get to know my friends
the way i know them
that's what surprised me is how open
they are and you see
even how they make a cocktail what their
kitchen looks like that's that's fun we
and that's what connects us a bit more
and i thought this is the moment where
we need to
stay connected and i think i just do it
in the way that i know how
yeah so i'm trying to get through like
everything that you have going on so
candyman yeah candyman too
so that's one of those movies that has
been delayed like what's your
is it frustrating for you too that like
something that you worked on is is
delayed for so long yeah you see it yeah
you get up to bat you're like oh we're
about to swing oh no we're not we're
gonna go back oh we're gonna switch have
you seen it
have you seen it oh you have i have seen
it and it's phenomenal but it does need
to be on a big screen i
i believe that i think it's um near the
cost of direct is something that's
really epic and it's really visually
stunning
and i think it needs i think you need to
be in an audience and
and and and be shocked at the same time
and laugh at the same time and
go out at the same time you know so i
think that's why it's being held off and
i think it's a good idea
yeah yeah now mia's gonna direct uh
captain marvel too so you're gonna get
into a marvel movie let's go
i'm ready i'm i'm ready listen i'm
getting my fight skills up
my body together i'm ready to marvel
marvel come on come on
yes you're shooting is season six of
fear of the walking dead so how's that
going
in terms of going well dude i think
we're having
the best season we've had um we keep
doubling down
and it keeps getting a bit more epic and
the characters get more size and my
character has been on it since the very
beginning
so i think my character has had lots of
um evolutions and now we're going into
strand
6.0 or 7.0 as we're about to start
shooting season seven
in another two months so i i love the
work and i love it's
it's fun it's epic storytelling but it's
just really about being human that's
what the show's about and that's why
there's always much more story to tell
right do you get scripts
and have that fears like am i getting
killed
you know i used to i used to always get
like the last pages to see if i die
yeah i don't know why but i feel like my
my character is like he's had nine lives
or something
i don't have that fear anymore i just
feel like if they're gonna kill me i
just want it to be a really good
storyline
i like i'm here for it if they decide to
kill me in the next episode
just let it be awesome you know
[Laughter]
so i think we kind of we got it all i
think we got it all in all those
projects it's
incredible how much you're doing coleman
like does does it overwhelm you
at times how much is going on sometimes
i've gotten very organized yeah i'm sure
i have a lot i have a lot of people like
who help
things out but um because it allows me
to just have that creative space so
anytime i could just like you know
i can get people to sort certain things
out so i can actually just be in the
moment because like like right here
with you i'm just with you i'm not
thinking about all the other stuff i'm
doing
so i just it just needs a team to help
you out so you know but i don't i don't
plan on stopping i
like i like working i like that that's
good that's good yeah because i want to
see more yeah they're amazing coleman
yeah so congratulations on everything
good luck in award season i think you
guys are going to do very well yeah
congratulations
thank you great to talk to you